[Music]
hi this is Don Fischer and I hope all of
you are as excited as I am to be part of
a revolution in the apparel retailing
industry the fact that we're selling
good quality and great style at very
competitive prices
puts us in a position to surprise the
industry I think this could be the
biggest division in the company in the
long run so good luck to all of you and
I'm going to keep an eye on each one of
your stores every single day
[Music]
this morning
Rogers from Rockefeller Center could be
their legs he's closing the gap uh well
in that just like Bush found the one
store in the country that's making money
he wants a separator with the store cab
directly to the dark a social media
celebrity for our planet and make a big
change when it comes to waste to the
help of New York film director Dan names
people asked repeatedly forget to stop
this start using wood
72 hours ago I was in the Brazilian
rainforest I saw their manes examples of
the impact humans have had on the earth
front on in so knowing I too and part of
the problem we are all part of the
problem with these videos they're not
normal show I connect with people and I
- I level around the globe which means a
lot and I mean a lot reply 29,000 387
emails so far to be exact and this
contributes to around 200 kilograms of
co2 into the Earth's atmosphere the same
amount emitted by Anik Donald's own
restaurants by way of comparison every
35 seconds we are all part of the
problem but before beating yourself up
about it to match this 21st century tale
of David versus Goliath will give you a
fresh perspective into tackling change
if you're still confused as to hit the C
Denver Lopez or the entire not normal
show as a whole that's totally cool I
brought this global map which you can
find on abnormal show.com where you
plant a seed which is an unfinished idea
in your city each week I choose a new
seed I fly to that city and complete it
with you before I unravel this seed I
just want to contextualize how I did the
selection process on this one because it
works a little bit differently I was in
an Airbnb house in the middle of the
rainforest not knowing where I was going
to head to next when I watched the video
two teenagers sent me on Instagram along
with a seed idea this is an open letter
to Dan mace only gap Incorporated and
the whole the whole the whole world this
is a story of two kids a massive
corporation and a plan to fight for
what's right for the last 18 months I've
worked here this is Old Navy you see old
Navy and it's business daddy gap you can
make billions of dollars a year but they
still actively choose to throw away
thousands of plastic hangers every
single day and if all of the over 1,000
Old Navy store
America throwaway hangers at the same
rate 5 million or more hangers are being
trashed each week placing total over 14
million pounds of plastic hangers into
landfills easier that's 7,000 tons and
you know it weighs 7,300 tons pardon my
french
the Eiffel Tower so Dan come on Dan hey
Dan Dan was good I'm talking to you Dan
we hope you see this and we hope even
more that you help us turn the seed into
something amazing
this was my chance to give back not only
by contributing awareness bits to hoping
expose a massive corporation that is
discarding more single-use plastics than
31,000 Americans every day that's the
whole city of Des Moines in Iowa every
week that's the population of the
country Cuba in one year this phone is
not about you it's about the gaps Old
Navy
therefore this week seed is by Jackson
Dumas harness the power of kids to
change the world
hashtag welcome to my weekly show not
normal food service my brainy secrets
deflection not switch mysteries
seems normal
are they corners of the earth that
haven't been exposed to plastic maybe
but probably not
it has boundless applications in the
modern world you'll find it in every
home office factory vehicle and lots of
public spaces too in 1869 John Hyde's
finalized the first synthetic polymer by
treating a natural polymer that makes up
the cell walls of plants cellulose
- when $10,000 put up by a New York firm
for anyone who could provide a
substitute for either manufacturing was
no longer limited by Nature plastics
were predicted to protect the
environment and its natural resources
pads like the in praise plastic as the
savior of the elephant and the tortoise
who knew that modern Turtles wouldn't
quite share the same sentiment in 1907
the first fully synthetic plastic was
invented cheap to produce valuable as
anything and virtually indestructible
it is in many ways a miracle product yet
for all its blessings and carries a
formidable curse Plastics don't
disappear they take at least 450 years
to biodegrade meaning the first piece of
plastic ever created is still some way
and we've created 10 billion tons more
since the nineteen fifties it was time
to meet the two Cedars for this week
[Music]
dude when I was 17 and I got a job at
Old Navy just so I could put gas in my
car I had no idea that two years later
I'd be making a film about how they
throw away thousands of plastic hangers
every single day and I've become so
passionate about this and I found out
that so many other people are so
passionate about this that we actually
have a shot at doing something about
this I'm just gonna pause there to add
that just prior to coming to New York
Jackson collected a week's worth of
single-use hangers from Old Navy in his
hometown and created this drone shut
then Santa T's boss with his resignation
how badass is that yeah but like our
seat idea is about the everyday person a
person's plastic consumption solution
it's about the big corporations that can
affect Nash
now like Old Navy I was taken back
because these teams reminded me so much
of myself when I was their age
my friend Jonah and I try to create
similar change by starting many
different plastic sustainability
campaigns like helped me to breathe
Blair which barbie and sprout about
which all didn't affect the change we
had hoped for but I guess that's why I
gravitated towards this idea
they are both such great quirky dudes
with massive hearts and a care for the
future of our planet I just wanted to do
some firsthand research so we headed to
one of the biggest of Old Navy stores in
the country
[Music]
they get they're not you know where they
gonna take on the garbage you know if
you guys like for you
honestly not surprised every single
store doesn't the only way to fake
change here would be to talk to someone
high up in their corporate structure so
he flew out to the San Francisco HQ the
next morning ironically on the day of
gapps 50th birth Nagaraj pretty nervous
in hope for a peaceful sit-down best
they wouldn't let us through the doors
and hired guards as well as policemen so
instead we rally together outside we're
a bunch of like-minded people started
joining every the police even state said
that God didn't have something to hide
after a short while their employees were
bunched on the rooftop deck looking down
at a smug group a passionate
changemakers pointing and laughing what
I hate is hi everyone to Siddhartha
from inside
everyone that comes outside thinks is a
huge
so so
like they taking photos and laughing at
us
not one person spoke to us not one we
did however make it or more than ten
different news stations around the
country and multiple other sources
coming to the table claiming the same
insights as us but even this didn't get
them talking day later they posted this
video on Instagram
Old Navy as well as the gap to say that
they do indeed care about the
environment but if you take a look at
the comment section you can quickly see
how people are aware of the damage that
the doctor and Old Navy day and still
nothing is changing and they're gonna
keep getting away with us unless we all
stand together and there's someone
inside the gap headquarters that's
watching this video decides to stand up
and do something now the point here is
to spotlight the big corporations like
Gap Inc and many others that are getting
away with hundreds of millions of tons
of harmful plastic waste every single
year with little to no accountability
because it's easier and makes a select
minority richer this may be nearing the
end of this week's video but it's in no
way nearing the end of this week see in
fact it's just the beginning we are
gonna keep coming after you gapping
until you make a change it's time to do
something don't forget you're awesome I
just want to say a huge thank you to my
sponsors B&H Photo Video and
so if you enjoyed this episode please
remember to hit the like button as well
as subscribe to future notifications bar
on next week I tell the story of what
went down in the Brazilian rain